自分は実は英語を教えるのが好きじゃないという事実
すべてのテレビ局がフードチャンネルであること顔がちっちゃ
っていうのは侮辱じゃないことほんじゃあに値する日本語
自分ほどアニメが好きな人がほとんどいないこと
進撃の巨人と罪の名はを知っている人を含みただ住民税が給料
から引かれていないことちょっと待って何これ後ろのパパーがライトをつけていても
自分が犯した犯罪がバレているとは限らないことちゃんとした食洗機が2週間で元が
取れること
ツンデレの意味一つから十までの助数詞だけ覚えたらいいこと多分
がいいえを意味すること誰か言うで同型トップ
靴を買えば仕事がデキると思われること仕事がデキると思われても仕事の効率が上がら
ないこと
チェーンつパワー椅子の存在はとがを a に間違えること自分より日本語が上手い
外国人を欄で言っても何も良いことはないこと歯医者さんに行くときは先に3万円下す
千代がないこと満員電車の写真では
サラリーマンの体臭とその背中の汗が伝わらないことそしてこたつの写真ではその
温もりと快適サーモ伝わらないことどうせならば常用の感じを全部来日してすぐ100
均に行けば
スーツケースは1個で済むこと背が高いと頻繁に腹筋をしないと確実に
うにゃになること一種のミンティアにカフェインが入っていることの気分位のメット秒
複合名詞の基本的なアクセント規則格安シームの存在国が少しずつ巨大な老人ホームに
変化しつつあること白人の髪を切るのを初めてたと言われたら大変危険であること隣の
おばあさんがくれるから
数
場に行ってサツマイモ彼を必要がないこと自分ががんばってままんだ名刺のほとんどが
カタカナ英語に変わりつつあることを彼というフレーズの万能性へこんだときに
ツイッターでボヤっとした日本について文句言っても何も良いことが起こらないこと
ナンパしてくる日本人は確かに多いけどその方
ほとんどが英語を練習したいおっさんであることというそうなんですね
という表現が早くたもなんかもう意味することを言葉でことの力パカたラーメンの旨さ
日本語お上手っていう言葉の意味
ni